hey what is going on YouTube oh god as
you can tell I have a cold
but you know as I said every Sunday I am
going to be doing a video so I'm going
to be doing a damn video it's not going
to be much of a funny video but you guys
heard me talk about this topic on JK
news but you know you guys don't want me
to elaborate on my channel so I'm going
to now recently a youtuber named Shane
Dawson I'm a senior now I'm not going to
get too much into the specifics you guys
can do your own research a lot of other
youtubers have talked about this so I'm
gonna give you a basic rundown so shake
off basically got outed by this camera
who he was talking to online you know
very sexually as most people do a cam
girl so basically in their DM she kind
of like took that screen capture pasted
it out and she just said well this is
how a family man talks to women blah
blah blah blah and topically speaking
for the headlines people are calling him
a cheater a horrible person or whatever
whatnot and if you guys are asking my
opinion on this let me just give you
guys a quick breakdown number one it
sucks you know I know of him but I don't
know too much about him but I saw his
channel and he's a family blob channel
he talks a lot about family values
hanging up with his you know five
beautiful kids his beautiful wife and
this type of thing comes up and it kind
of tarnishes his brand and his name when
you're a youtuber and there's like a lot
of people who follow you and idolize who
you are as a human being it affects more
than just your personal life it kind of
says everybody that follows you which is
which is crazy a lot of like social
media people or people who are clinical
celebrities do realize that your actions
and what you do when the stuff that you
put out really does affect other people
so short after he put on an apology
saying that he had a sick mind he's been
drinking recently he's been stressed out
he's tired of living this response and
he's just going to stop making videos
for a little bit until he gets better
now here's my opinion on this first of
all to the cam girl what the [ __ ]
clearly she wasn't doing this for some
kind of moral thing there was a couple
of interviews where she said like he was
talking to me like I like I was an
object a piece of meat
she was offended apparently to certain
reports that he said a comment called a
disgusting because she mentioned that
his kid was cute so for him it was kind
of like well you're kind of crossing the
boundaries between reality and
personality that I have don't do that so
we got freaked out probably shouldn't
call disgusting the point of me saying
that is that obviously she didn't really
do it for like any moral reason she
wasn't trying to help his family out he
wasn't trying to help his wife out so if
any of you out there think that she did
this noble thing because she is this you
know hardcore like you know you should
respect and treat women well say it's
not that you obviously wanted some
[ __ ] attention you [ __ ] number two
people are saying that he cheated on her
now cheating is a very relative term
um cheating is a very harsh term do I
personally think that he cheated on his
wife in an emotional sense probably yeah
by the way if you read the text that he
was you know writing to the girl
actually it was like along the lines of
like yeah I'm gonna stick my dick in
your ear poke your [ __ ] my but the tip
of my dick in your retina no and
obviously he has a which is hyper
aggressive like sexual cyber the
cheating part comes where you don't
communicate with the person that you're
with and your wife and if you wanted to
explore certain options or that was
something that was falling apart you
should be open enough to talk to your
partner about it so in that sense I
guess like emotionally there was some
cheating involved and it also depends
too if you're in a relationship and the
person that you're with is or is not
okay with you watching porn if she's
okay with you watching porn is it really
cheating to meet probably not at number
three the biggest message that I want to
get across and it's something that I
always bring up on my channel and I
stress all the time [ __ ] just be
yourself be honest with who you are and
I did a video not too long ago where I
told you social media is not real and
people sometimes don't seem to
understand this and I keep saying and it
just goes right over your [ __ ] head
so I'm just going to say it again
because you guys do follow me and you do
sometimes listen to what I'm saying so
I'm saying one more time how many times
do I have to tell people social media is
not real it is not a real representation
of who these people are but I always
tell people man just if you're going to
do something do it wholeheartedly and be
yourself because if you're going to keep
up the facade you have to do it for the
rest of your [ __ ] life can you act
and not be who you really are in front
of the whole world to the day that you
[ __ ] die are you in
life is way too [ __ ] short the guy is
a bit of a [ __ ] freak but he built
this channel on this brand based on him
being this wholesome like family I wish
you know he probably is I'm guarantee
you he's great to his his wife he's
great to encase you know a majority the
time he defends his beard [ __ ] fetish
and he didn't know what to do with it
and so he laptop to this girl Taylor
it's so [ __ ] fascinating how you guys
keep seeing this [ __ ] over and over and
I and I just really want people to
understand it because you keep seeing
all these youtubers come out with their
depression all this like scandal like oh
my god I thought this guy was the most
positive [ __ ] human being on earth you
know he does this he talks about his
charity work he does all that does the
main [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot of people out
there have this concept that is not
posted if I don't publicize it that is
not real and the things that people post
and write and Instagram about is more
their real life than what they're
actually doing think about that [ __ ] the
weirdest thing now is that people can
better fabricate a life than live a life
now here's the thing and I'm gonna take
this to the grave with me because I'm
not saying this from somebody who hadn't
experienced this himself when I was
younger man like I wanted to be
everything that I wasn't I don't know
with a bad crowd because I thought I
could do the stuff that they were doing
but I could so every day I would put up
this stupid [ __ ] front and act like
something I was you know what here to
change it I'll put like this if you guys
go to my youtube videos go to the very
first time I ever blog it was like being
in San Diego cracking jokes or some
[ __ ]
and I was super calm I was like yeah hey
so this is what did Papa Bob LA I didn't
talk like that the first time I spoke
like myself was at UCLA Alexander
Wallace for you and that was Who I am
loud as [ __ ] opinionated as hell and
people responded to that every time that
you go out there and you pretend like
you are something that you are not that
thing inside you just starts to fester
and it just grows bigger and bigger and
bigger until it [ __ ] leaks out or
ripped out or destroyed you but if you
recognize who you are or if you even
recognize the issues that you have in
terms of this guy in his sexuality and
he's talked about it spoke about it with
family his life the people that he was
close to he could have better dealt with
it I'm pretty sure there's a lot of
people office who look at my channel
this guy's obnoxiously the piece of [ __ ]
he always talks about [ __ ] that he
doesn't know about when he says certain
things later on he takes it back yeah of
course I do [ __ ] because I'm
face value yeah I may say things that
yeah I kind of believe it at the time
but there could've been somebody else I
met they changed my [ __ ] in my soul
course from a changed my opinion I'm not
gonna stick to my guns if I was [ __ ]
wrong and if somebody corrected me
you know I will go with the [ __ ] that's
correct I'm not that stubborn you know
my father told me something a long time
ago and it always stuck with me um
because I'm pretty sure she saw me
growing up like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are man your kid you got a
good family you got a mom you got a roof
what weekend you left blue in your
stomach and you act like you just you
know like you like this good ass stupid
kid and you're not bad you know she told
me this and and I and I really kind of
took it to heart if you live honest life
there is nothing bad that can happen to
you not in the sense that there's not
bad things that will come your way is
that if you know that you have done
everything right you can live at peace
with yourself
it doesn't mean that if you're an honest
person other people are going to be
honest and not trying to take you down
but you can be confident in your choices
they know that you were in the right
that you stuck to your guns that when
you go to sleep you can go to sleep at
night just to top it off there might be
a few people who disagree with me on
certain points and that's completely
fine um but at the end of the day this
dude I don't know you man but you know I
don't know don't kill and beat yourself
up so much just be honest with yourself
and just learn how to communicate a
little better and you'll be okay not to
tell yourself that you're a sick [ __ ]
freak yeah you had a big you know you
talked to a cam girl and you know she
got what she wanted out of me she was
talking to a famous guy she even said it
herself like who
how why would I ever deny talking to
somebody that famous who would so
obviously her motives weren't really
pure herself and it for her once again
and I say this if you felt like he was
using you for cam girl purposes that's
exactly what he was doing whether it was
on a DM or not you know if you thought
it was something more than that and
that's something that you guys probably
should have communicated but don't try
to come out and act like you're the
[ __ ] angel and his victim in this
situation but
[ __ ] I call [ __ ] on that in the
comments below what do you think because
you know there's some people out there
who are his fans and how did you view
him as and when this new change you how
did it affect you how did it make you
feel because I'm pretty sure if you guys
saw you know new came about me where I
was jacking off to a picture of a
[ __ ] pumpkin you guys just left okay
what is going on YouTube so the other
topic that a lot of people mentioned and
once again I'm sorry that I'm taking my
voices out but um yeah I'm just uh you
know you know my heart goes out to
people like this and you guys put your
your lives out there sometimes keep
things like this happen in your strata
be prepared for it so leave whatever you
guys want me to talk about I'm here for
you man like we're going to do this I
don't have a lot of time nowadays but I
can make class beyond so I'll see y'all
next week